I am Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight the
Kaepernick myth that's the focus of
tonight's angle
all right just when you thought you'd
heard the last of the NFL quarterback
Colin Kaepernick he resurfaces to
promote yet another groundbreaking
project that he co-authored
Colin Kaepernick has got a powerful
message for younger people in his new
book he says stand up for what you
believe in part of the goal in telling
the story is you know take pride in your
Blackness take pride in your culture My
Hope Is young people and readers walk
away and they seize their power
nothing wrong with that at all everyone
should take pride in their background
and who they are after all Kaepernick
himself led a Charmed Life adopted at
five weeks old by parents who by his own
account loved and supported him
your dad and I have had so many proud
moments since the day you came into our
lives you've always been very persistent
and tenacious in pursuit of anything
that you desired but I admire that trade
in you as well because it's what took
you to fulfillment of your dreams
an upper middle class upbringing in
California nice house nice Community a
top athlete in school both baseball and
football probably could have played in
the major leagues his parents sacrificed
to make sure that he had every
opportunity to succeed and he reached
the Pinnacle all the way to the Super
Bowl for the 49ers
but the moment he decided to take a knee
to protest police brutality Kaepernick
found himself a career that provided
better pay and more job security than
anything he'd ever do on the football
field
de facto president of racial victimology
Inc he was the perfect vessel into which
the media and America hating leftists
could pour their enthusiastic support
the off-season for Colin Kaepernick
looks much different these days the 35
year old has a non-profit a publishing
company and media projects including a
docu-series on Netflix and an upcoming
documentary with director Spike Lee
that is some big bank and if it means
throwing your parents under the bus to
promote your comic book then why not
it's his true High School coming-of-age
Story his journey embracing his
Blackness despite resistance from many
including his white adoptive parents I
know my parents love me but there were
still very problematic things that
I went through I think it was important
to show that no this can happen in your
own home and how we move forward
collectively while addressing the racism
that is being perpetuated
now the comic book shows young
Kaepernick becoming a fan of NBA star
Alan Iverson and wanting to emulate his
on-court look
teenage Kaepernick wanted cornrows to
match he's getting what roles his mom
asked oh your hair is not professional
oh you look like a little Thug
yeah and those become spaces where it's
like okay how do I navigate this
situation now
is that what you say as a teenager how
do I navigate the situation oh who knows
what happened in his house or what his
parents said but there's only one reason
why that little drive by anecdote about
his hair was included it was to sell
Kaepernick Inc but at some point they're
going to run out of victim myth material
he'd already dramatized the entire scene
in his Netflix special you have to cut
your hair if you're going to stay on the
team truth be told you do look
unprofessional you're cutting your hair
Colin I don't want to too bad why we
told you it's a team rule but why
because you look like a thug
now the message is deeply corrosive
especially to children
that white people are inherently racist
and even dangerous and that unless
they're atoning for their ingrained
racism unless they declare themselves
allies and the bogus anti-racism
movement
they're irredeemable
even if those white individuals Are
Family
and devoted their life to their minority
child
but in the end this really isn't even
about Colin Kaepernick it's about what
the left has done to destroy hope
optimism and Truth in America
the leftist failed American working
people at every turn but especially
minorities
cities that they run have become havens
of Decline and despair
Biden's open border has kept drugs
flooding into the poorest of poor
neighborhoods
liberal DA's in the defund the police
movement that Kaepernick himself
supports have helped spark a crime wave
that has killed countless people of
color
but they want black and brown people in
America to believe that the real problem
are the 74 million people who voted for
Donald Trump this mager crowd is really
the most extreme political organization
that's existed in American history
and recent American history
think about how far the Democrats have
fallen
Bill Clinton was a man from Hope
Obama was about Hope and change
and now we have Biden
poison in his long haunted and plagued
donation we Face deep racial inequities
in American System systemic racism that
has plagued our nation for far far too
long
versus Board of Education
Civil Rights Act of 1964 the work of
Martin Luther King Jr
and Obama as a two-term president of the
United States
and now the left's main argument is that
nothing has improved for Black America
it's all rotten and racist in the
country
well black wages were increasing under
Donald Trump
black unemployment was the lowest in 50
years under Trump
and minorities today have reached the
top of every profession in this country
in the media and Corporate America in
sports entertainment and Far Beyond
so it is a vicious hateful lie to imply
that most of America is so infected by
racism that the system is rigged
that only big government is the answer
in fact big government is a trap
just look at what big government did to
schools in urban America
but in the end the media will always
promote the fact that they believe
racism you know poisons any efforts to
build relationships between white people
and people of color
rather than celebrate biracial adoptions
or biracial marriages the left is now
treating them with automatic suspicion
that really does say it all
now let's be candid if Kaepernick's
message in his new graphic novel was
about how much he loved America how
blessed he was to have such selfless
adoptive parents
you know he wouldn't be rich and he
wouldn't have his own publishing company
or a Netflix deal
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else